hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the magnus carlson chess tour
it's hikaru nakamura versus magnus
carlsen and this is game one of their
third match uh just uh you know
check up on what's happening first match
was won by hikaru second was won by
magnus and this is not the third match
and as we know the finals are the best
of seven so already
uh for some reason there is something on
the board but uh you probably already
know
what happened uh again we have the
berlin defense so let's just go
straight into it with e4 e5 knight f3
knight c6 and
bishop to b5 the rule lopez is on the
board
knight to f6 and now d3 so not going for
the quick drawish line we've seen
yesterday or rather we haven't seen
unless you've
checked out the the live coverage bishop
to c5
by magnus and now a nice straight on c6
captures captures and knight beat the b2
this knight is coming to c4 to go after
the e5 pawn
and so on the usual uh berlin stuff uh
with castles by
magnus and the knight to the c for now
and now you need to defend it with
knight to d7 so the pawn is now nicely
defended
uh or rather you could try and and grab
the pawn however if you
if you grab the pawn then just knight
captures knight captures and
the problem is queen to d4 with an
attack on the knight and of course
threatening checkmate so uh you don't
want to do this so this is just
castles uh and now uh the most common
one is rookie a2 and now the defender
of the pawn is now the white king safely
castle
uh however magnus goes for a somewhat
rarer line with f6
it's not a rare move of course f6 play
is played in pretty much
uh every line of the berlin uh but here
it's just uh
the second favorite so here a4 now with
a5 not allowing white to push further
and now bishop to e3 and this is a new
move in the position
uh here c3 is a known move uh even
charge played against ivan ceoparino in
the
tournament of peace in zagreb in 2018
and won a very nice game however here we
have bishop to e3 by nakamura
and it is as of move attended we have a
completely new game so let's see what uh
what magnus does here we have b6
uh preparing to get the lights for
bishop into the game
uh and now comes h4 by nakamura
uh we have quinta e8 now maybe with
ideas of shifting the queen into the
game and
now g3 just strengthening that h4 pawn
we have bishop back to e7 and now
knights the e1 shifting the knight over
to g2
uh and from there maybe uh in the future
some h5 ids knight h4 knight can come to
e3 maybe and so on
so here it knights to c5 uh and now
knight the g2 as planned with bishop to
e6 and now
b3 so you can see this very weird setup
by hikaru here
not not seen every day i don't know if
it maybe maybe it even has a name i
don't know
uh but it it is very interesting you
know developing your
your wings like this uh queen to d7
now connecting rooks uh and preparing
some ideas of maybe infiltrating with
the bishop would bishop the g4
also f5 might be an idea at some point
so queen e2
also connects rooks prepares to bring
the rooks into the game rook 8
e8 uh and now f3 strengthening e4
and waiting to see what magnus will do
and here magnus finds a very very
interesting plan
so uh he not going with something like
bishop here now the g4 square no longer
is available to the bishop but now
magnus finds
captures because after f3 was played the
g3 pawn was weakened and this is what
magnus uses
bishop captures we have d captures on c4
now okay nakamura nicely
can use the d file for his rooks but
queen to h3
and this is all made possible by the
weakening of the g3 pawn so king of two
defending
and now now magnus uh goes back because
there is the threat if you
if you play f5 a rook h1 traps the queen
or or does it uh this is the fun stuff
because this is in fact the strongest
idea for black here you have to
sacrifice the knight
knight captures on e4 f cap sorry f
captures f captures now with a
discovered check and now the queen gets
a square so king g1
the g3 point is no longer defended queen
captures
and we get this very nice position uh
where uh
white is up a piece but in a very very
difficult position and for a rapid game
i
i i guess it's uh much easier to play
this with black rook to f3 is coming the
other rook is coming to a fade the
bishop
can pretty much choose where it's going
so uh very very very tough to play this
for white
in a rapid game however magnus decides
to prepare it so he goes queen back to
e6 now prepares f5 but now he carl just
brings the king back he does
doesn't want his uh king on the f file
that will soon open up so here
f5 by magnus and now we have characters
we have captures and the rook
a to d1 uh but now uh it's a bit
different because now
there is again something in the position
i'm not going to tell you what it is but
uh feel free to pause the video and what
would you play in this position
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on going back and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's queen to h3 again
again threatening to pick up this g3
pawn and now what do you do here
well now there are a couple of ways to
deal with this you could advance the
pawn to g4 but
that kind of leaves the h4 pawn under
attack if you try king to f2
uh then the problem is knight the e4
check the f file is now open
and now white's entire position just
crumbles you have to move the king
doesn't matter where you move it king
goes here knight comes to g3 attacks the
queen
the rook and so on so queen to h3
incredibly problematic for hikaru so he
tries to bishop the f2 instead
uh defends it like this closes up the f
file additionally but now
bishop to d6 by magnus so what do you
what do you do now
uh rook f the e1 and now rook to e7 now
the other rook is coming to the f file
as well
we have queen to e3 now preparing to
push f4 so you can counter that rook
rookie uh e to f7 and now f4
but now we have uh e captures on f4 g
captures an a4
and now okay now you don't want to
capture right away so first magnus just
pins the knight and now
everything will just pile up on that f4
pawn and then the on the f2 bishop and
so on
so here queen e2 hikaru of course wants
to trade queens
but magnus says not a problem i'm just
going to grab a pawn or two while we do
it and then i'm just going to have a
very pleasant endgame so he goes rook
captures an f4
uh queen captures with rook captures and
now rook to d4
now immediately offering a rook trade
but magnus just goes rook to g6 he wants
to go after this pawn
as it's an isolated pawn and it will be
a weakness so here h5 we have rook to h6
and now rook to h4 defending the pawn
but now rook to f5
attacking the pawn twice and there is no
way to defend it
once more so bishop e3
hikaru even forces this trade rook
captures we have rook captures
rook captures and bishop therefore now
hikaru further offer traits
uh over straight bishop captures knight
captures and now rook to f5
and here knight to e6 offering yet more
trades
knight captures rook captures and now
after all is said and done we're in this
position where
the material on the board is completely
equal on the queen side however on the
king side magnus has two connected past
pawns
and this is of course winning so c5 uh
and then now comes
rook to e7 goes after this pawn but it's
one pawn you can give it up so magnus
just starts pushing the past pawns h5
with rook captures on c7 and now king to
h7
bringing the king into the game king g2
with king to h6 and now c3 preparing b4
but it is of little use so uh rook to f6
not allowing any
rook to c6 check ideas uh even though
you don't really care about it
rook the c8 by hikaru and now came the
g5
we have rook to d8 and now king the g4
there are no checks so you don't have to
worry about that and the pass pawn is
now marching forward with b4 by hikaru
and here magnus just played h4
uh and he was in this position animal 45
that hikaru nakamura resigned the game
and we have this very nice victory by
magnus carlsen
uh using none other than the berlin
defense
and uh here you resign because like we
said you have to connect the
past pawns here you will rather your
opponent does and it's just very easy to
play this you're just going to push this
push that and the rook will be helpless
so of course both magnus and kykar know
this
and that's why he resigned and already
something very interesting happened in
game two game two
also uh just finished like incredibly
quickly
where magnus had the white pieces and
they again played the berlin
but now it's magnus who took the very
early draw uh
because he says okay i won with the
black pieces like you did
you know yesterday and i'm just going to
take draw with white and i'm going to
play my preparation in the berlin again
i'm very happy to you know show you the
stuff with with the black pieces
so really really incredible match uh
both hikaru and magnus uh seemingly just
playing with
the black pieces so very very very
interesting stuff
so uh that's uh the game i do hope you
enjoyed it magnus takes the early lead
in match three
now i would like to thank uh mandy
koshal uh brian powell cindy harris
james morris and russell lloyd for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here uh or rather it's
here
yeah or oh yeah there they are um
and yeah see you soon guys